[Musique]
des retrouvailles un peu fraîche devant
la fontaine de trevi à rome emmanuel
macron salut du point boris johnson et
doit jouer un peu des coudes pour
prendre sa place lors de la photo de
famille courage c'est minimum syndical
pour un président de la république des
vins de son pays et ses pêcheurs qui
sont bien en difficulté parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'accord en fait y'a pas score et
quand on s'aperçoit qu'il ya pas
d'accord et qu'on essaie de trouver un
accord on voit qu'on a pas d'accord
parce qu'on est en désaccord bon alors
donc il n'y a pas d'accord la balle est
dans le camp des britanniques nous leur
avons remis une proposition
est donc si les britanniques continuent
à nous d'y réagir comme s'il ne voulait
pas mettre en oeuvre un accord
ce qui a été signé
commencé à bouger je le regretterai mais
nous ne pouvons pas ne pas répondre et
ne pas défendre nos pêcheurs en huit
lots qui tranche avec la mise en scène
affiché de la réconciliation entre
emmanuel macron et joe biden ce que nous
avons fait était maladroit ou une ds3
mais cela n'a pas été fait beaucoup
d'élégance heures
j'avais l'impression que certaines
choses devaient être faites mais ne se
sont pas faites pour à nous faire croire
que l'incident est passé avec ça entre
un coup de fil voilà quelques semaines
et puis ensuite cette poignée de main
qu'on va penser ça y est qu on passe
l'épongé
la france avec monsieur macro est de
moins en moins une puissance on a
convoqué l'ambassadeur on annule un
dîner de gala et puis c'était tout est
là maintenant monsieur by the indie
dance et une maladresse tout ce que vous
le saviez ah ben on le savait alors
comment se fait-il donc là je crois que
nous avons une position de grande
faiblesse face à l' empire américain et
policiers choqués par la découverte
d'inscriptions dans un hall d'immeuble
vendredi soir regardez ce qui a été
écrit sur un mur c'est un tableau de
primes mais impunité qui tentera de
gangréner la société penser que gérald
darmanin laisse les policiers se faire
agresser par l'allée sandillon ça fait
combien de temps que ça dure ce n'est
pas nouveau vous en parler aujourd'hui
c'est odieux ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui ne peut pas y avoir de
provocation
comme celle ci qui restent impunis et
donc je peux vous dire que la police
judiciaire est saisie par le parquet de
cette affaire afin que nous retrouvions
les responsables qu'est ce que vous leur
mettez est ce que c est ce que c'est
digne d'un ex président de la république
est pourquoi je ne donnerai pas mon avis
sur le désordre et la confusion
politique d'aujourd'hui françois
hollande qui dit hier il n'ya pas d'un
quart nation qui permet d'avoir
l'espérance d'être au second tour
aujourd'hui pour la gauche voilà
d'incarnation dont rivale misseriya
douala mais est-ce que vous pendre quand
il dit ça il laisse entendre que vous ne
pouvez pas d'incarner et moi vous savez
les on laisse entendre et on interprète
est on sûr interprète exe moore une
nouvelle fois chahuté à nantes pour y
était venu faire la promotion de son
livre plusieurs centaines de personnes
ont voulu bloquer l'accès au zénith les
forces de l'ordre ont dû intervenir et
faire usage de gaz lacrymogènes les
manifestants des anti fades et gilet
jaune se dirige alors vers la voie
rapide en face du zénith certains s'en
prennent à du mobilier urbain qui
sème la tempête qui sème le vent récolte
la tempête le gouvernement je le trouve
complices de cette situation complices
oui vous savez pourquoi monsieur macron
j'ai appris ça dans un livre monsieur
macron dernièrement a reçu monsieur
zemmour a complimenté pour ça je cite sa
vision comprenant même je cite son point
de vue pardon hein mais j'allais dire un
gros mot mais sûre c'est cette
candidature d'un guignol mais c'est un
guignol qui est en train de porter notre
pays vraiment dans une situation qui ne
correspond en rien à ses valeurs être la
cible privilégiée de tous ces pseudos
anti fasciste est une médaille pour moi
c'est ma fierté et c'est ma gloire que
je veux partager avec d accident
horrible des incidents ça survient sur
les tournages mais de cette nature
jamais il y avait une chance sur un
milliard pour que ça survienne